snap out of cryo and turn up the heat
because it's episode four of night
flyers so prepare to get probed Eris
lays in the dirt because this is the
only place he can get rid of the sound
of his mother's voice who we learn can
control the entire ship well a boy's
best friend is his mother
Mel visits him and tries to quell his
fears by giving him a big kiss and it
looks like Cynthia Eris is still at work
creating more hallucinations for Carl
his daughter who we learned last episode
was afflicted with the sealeo virus
asked him to cut out the cancer inside
her but Rowan tells him just walked
through it it's just a projection but
even weirder is that the White Rabbit
probe which was launched in episode 2
has somehow made its way a million miles
back right into Carl's room
and it looks visibly beat-up how did it
get here well judging by the smirk on
Carl's face he might have an answer Roy
and Mel get intimate which I'm sure
lonely will enjoy when she finds that
out but before anything can happen mama
heiress creeps on them sending messages
to his son lemis hard at work when the
ship undergoes a sudden reboot likely
the result of a furious Cynthia watching
her son go to bone town 9 she
experiences another quick flashback of
the man with lacerations we saw back in
episode 2
well this loading dock worker gets
trapped in the cargo bay Agatha checks
up on Thea when we catch a brief glimpse
of an image of Carl with the surrounding
blurred-out this obviously has something
to do with a hidden past of Agatha and
Carl which we'll learn a little bit
later on in the episode they'll even
calls her out saying you're thinking of
de Brannon again and things don't look
good for loading dock guy who attempts
to stop a gas leak but he immediately
freezes and they'll can feel it too back
at probe central Carl's only explanation
is that this must be the Vulcans way of
communicating with them how else could
have magically reappear in his room in
the meantime he wants the probe studied
with 24-hour camera surveillance in case
anything happens
Agatha informs Eris that one of his crew
members is hurt but they just don't know
where instead of getting your security
detail act that suggests that him along
with they'll go searching in an effort
to regain each other's trust what could
go wrong Carl and Rowan bring lomi to
the probe hoping they might start
getting some answers we learn row and
touch the probe to get samples of the
space rust which is built up on the
outside perhaps that could be linked to
why
goes crazy at the end they'll brings
heiress and Agatha to the cargo bay
where our unfortunate worker has
succumbed to the extreme cold and beerus
don't you do it don't Oh eres lo me
asked them to turn the heat down but
learns the sad reality it's Eris's
mother who has been screwing with her
every time she logs onto the ship and
now she's purposely making it extremely
hot they all seems to be a bit jealous
of Agatha and Carl's past connection
Agatha does admit that they used to be
close but how close well we'll get to
that Eris explains to Mel that it had to
be his mother who closed the cargo doors
resetting the system herself and not
giving a warning to the crew he demands
he be led into Carl's quarters and
overrides the door only to be given the
biggest migraine of his life by his
screaming mother who wants the probe off
her ship I was probed but more
interesting is this quick image we see
which judging by the old lamps on the
side my best guess this is coming from
Cynthia's cabin which we saw briefly
last episode what this device is we're
still unsure but perhaps it could be
Cynthia's AI and Agatha's feelin all
nostalgic because she taps into the
memory machine to relive what is
actually a pretty sad memory this would
have had to take place at least over 10
years ago and we learned Carl and Agatha
had a thing but she abruptly left him
without any contact Carl got roasted
hardcore and moved on eventually falling
in love with joy eros orders the probe
be destroyed and refers to it as a
cancer needing to be removed
just like how Carl's daughter's
projection in the beginning said she
needed her cancer removed Carl pleads
saying how can they possibly get rid of
the only thing which had likely made
alien contact eros compromises and gives
him one cycle to do his research before
that thing will be cut up and sent out
the airlock Carl and Agatha discuss a
bit of their past but notice here how
Carl is still holding on to his
daughters friendship bracelet they're
interrupted by Rowan who's like you
really got to see this and what a
discovery it is the probe is bleeding
Rowan unlatches the internal drive and
shows them that it's alive whatever
forces at play here it's definitely
alien Mel tries to reason with eros
about his struggle with his mother but
is dismissed when Eris says his mother
warned him she'd try to do this this AI
is extra
intelligent accurately able to foresee
how other people in the ship will react
and right now I think we can all agree
this AI has been way more detrimental to
the ship than the probe okay what the
hell is this hands up if you call this a
dream the moment had happened and what
the hell is happening with his pants
did he just i Karl the team pull out
pieces of organic material from the
probe wondering if it's some sort of
message this organic material reminds me
a lot of the chunks of meat we found in
the very first episode when Rowan
attacks perhaps whatever this probe
brought back on board won't have the
best of consequences Karl is convinced
that the Vulcan must have the ability to
control space-time but they'll need lomi
to go in and extract some information
and she has to go in before the heat
destroys all the data the results of the
blood tests come up and shockingly the
DNA matches Carl's and Rowan says he's
taking control the study quoting you can
no longer study the phenomenon because
you are the phenomenon and Roy goes full
Norman Bates as the voices of his mother
are too much for him to handle absolute
truth you can see the weird pinkish
device we saw earlier behind his bed
Carl ventures into the corridor for some
air when he's confronted by both his
daughter and Agatha both of whom are
projections
Agatha taunts him telling him the life
they could have had and proceeds to cut
out their baby
lomi taps into the probe and is
instantly jettisoned into this rich
galaxy like world which they'll also
somehow taps into Carl leaves a message
for joy seeing that if she wants to get
rid of him since he reminds her of his
daughter he understands and he takes off
his wedding ring showing that things are
over but instead of sending the message
he saves it for later
lomi looks like she's in a state of
euphoria when Carl walks in and Rowan
discovers she's already locked herself
into the probe bonus points if you
notice Rowan holding the same saw Agatha
cuts herself with in episode 1 lomi goes
full Exorcist while the organic material
around them reacts but it doesn't last
long and she comes out of it not before
the entire probe dies in a fountain of
blood and as if things couldn't get any
worse for Carl he finds out that Agatha
carried a child his and whether she
aborted it or if it was a miscarriage we
just aren't sure
Rowan calls it a day and has asked by
Eris if they found anything from the
probe he then reminds Eris his mother
won't stop
the probe she'll keep screwing things up
the closer and closer they get to the
Volk Hren Karla suomi what she saw on
the probe and she describes it as a
beautiful chaos a nod back to last
episode where Owen tells Tessie a true
nature is chaos but Tasya refutes this
saying if you look close enough you'll
find order amongst the chaos and the
episode ends with the cliffhanger that
the probe was indeed a message but the
timestamps on the internal drives say
that it was out in space for over a
thousand years perhaps karl is right the
Volk run can manipulate space-time and
if it's true what does that mean for our
crew thanks everyone for watching if
you're enjoying my breakdowns please
give it a like share and subscribe I'm
gonna keep plugging away at them and I
hope you'll tune in until next time
remember daddy loves you very much